and this movies been playing for 1,250
two weeks and five days in theaters
that's 24 years non-stop this whole
story started because my friend
recommended that I watched this movie
well this is a crazy film and as usual I
had to do some research this seems like
a story for us I'm in Mumbai this is the
Maratha Mandir theater and it's become
famous for one thing
the film is called Dilwale Dulhaniya Le
Jayenge ghee or DDLJ affectionately it's
India's version of the Titanic but the
actors became ten times more famous it
has way more hit song
sorry swing and it's a film today that's
still relevant after so many years we
asked the ticket seller if people are
really still coming to see it mostly job
security already rated movies and do a
general order to review those deals are
the things which are so critical every
day except for one at 11:30 a.m.
they've been screening this movie in
this theatre so we're gonna talk to the
projectionists
Madame Andermatt 46 Falcon catalyst
altar dilwale dulhaniya Japs Allah gives
opera buffa David Salmonella ribbon Noah
Jabbar de cámara favorite film will last
will manger bombers very tragic AHA
Trotter KK time or mad March or data
just Imran is still our Castle yada
popular duty or query concept or yes
there are bhatia telugu movie okay let
me tell you about the film because if
you're still watching you're probably
curious this is Raj played by Shahrukh
Khan and this is Simran played by the
famous actress Kajol they meet on a
train they end up in Switzerland
Simran's drunk and on a trolley they
sing they dance they're in love no
they're not
wait yes they are but Simran has an
arranged marriage back in India to this
guy so Raj follows her there they have
an iconic moment in a mustard field he
pretends to be a family friend
they sneak around the family loves him
yay wait Simmons dad does not does it
matter
I don't know the truth comes out turns
out it did matter punches are thrown
Simmons fiance loses Raj and Simran
leave on a train together the end may
Dominic in the Sun may sabe party only a
picture daqu look above 95 personnel
they came like over a billion people
japanese
ddle bigger yes yes I've seen have you
seen DDLJ yes
yes remember the cookie I'm a I'm a shy
guy didn't exhibit oh my god he's right
as an American this seems just like a
classic love story but clearly there's
something more going on so I spoke to an
optometry prep
she's a film critic here in India and
the woman who literally wrote the book
I'm DDLJ my book was called the valley
Dulhaniya Le Jayenge a modern classic
and the idea was to explore why DDLJ
became the cult that it did before DDLJ
people when you fell in love it was it
was just so more formal and also you
have to understand this film released at
a time when this country had just opened
up the economy had just opened up you
know it was urban India was in such a
massive state of flux and this will told
you that it doesn't matter that then you
could wear the blue jeans and you could
wear the foreign clothes but your heart
was still Indian and that's an
irresistible message the collective
experience has become so magical that it
just keeps fueling itself so I think it
completely changes the whole narrative
and it set a tone for Hindi cinema for
many years before we left we went and
spoke with the owner I wanted to know
why he was still playing this movie
after 24 years I myself have seen this
film at least 2025 m's what I have done
was I like this there is a song made
deal about I reckon our Judy Sasaki
recognized Lani
and to think I got to learn all this
because they googled the movie in my
living room one day
[Music]
[Music]